joining us now one of the greats
the Georgetown New York Knicks legend
Patrick Ewing I'm good who was second in
recruiting you go to Georgetown but
where was the other school who was
second runner-up UCLA really yes you
still it was my my second choice when
they let me get back on that plane and
that long it's like back to Boston I was
like uh no who would you play because
Reggie was there in the mid-80s who was
who was at UCLA at that time when you
went out to visit rocket rod foster like
a whole can't remember the rest of the
guys Larry Brown was the coat rocket
would would have been fun to play with
yeah you know because back then yeah you
know people are remembering back then
but back then I was lost slim and I said
I just want a little what do you
remember about your first NCAA
tournament well were you 18 at the time
yeah I was 18 it was great you know I we
were fortunate to be one of the top seed
we went out west we kicked butt took
names made it to the finals and lost
some some school down here in North
Carolina
oh boy how often just really got robbed
oh oh you did yeah you know I they
called me for about five seven go ten
and maybe one of them might have been
wait didn't you start the game just
goaltending everything does how often
does Jordan bring up that national title
you know what he doesn't bring it up
that much he brings up other things like
NBA championships the NBA championship
the fact that I've never beaten them
when it counted oh you know yeah both of
you you as you and I know him he talks a
lot of trash but he brings up the NBA
stuff more than the college does what do
you remember though about Freddy Brown
when that happened so Jordan hits the
jumper Freddy goes down at the other end
10 seconds left he spot he somehow you
know mistake ins James Worthy for a
teammate throws in the ball you guys
lose that game you go in the locker room
what does the locker room like and what
is what do you say to Freddy Brown um
you know the play that plays happens a
lot in the game it just was so
unfortunate that it happened at that
time usually when it happens it doesn't
happen at the end of the game is more in
the flow of the game and you know all I
don't even remember what we said to him
if we said anything to him I know coach
gave him a big hug he told him it was
gonna be alright so I think everybody
else just you know follow lead you know
as it was a unfortunate mistake that
happened at the wrong time what's the
ball going to you more like sleepy oh
you think summers gonna take the last
shot Oh sleepy was gonna definitely take
the last try to either one of us who got
the ball would have taken the last
either he or I but probably him back
then you know sleeping a lot of people
don't remember sleepy I think he's
deleting still the leading scorer at
Georgetown but he shot that bad boy
every time he says he put up some pretty
good numbers well even in the pros I
remember he had 15 in the game yeah he
had a great college running also great
NBA run I think he still holds the
record for most points in a half or in a
court or one of them oh yeah that he was
up there I don't know if klay Thompson
passed him for most points in the
quarter but I know sleep he was up there
I'm I was also wondering this with Dirk
Nowitzki getting over 30,000 points
could you have been a Dirk Nowitzki type
like would your game as great a jump
shooters you were in the pros would you
have been extended a little bit further
if you're coming up now because of you
know Dirk Nowitzki you know I you know
people asked for that question a lot and
you know my game was was you know I
guess my era my game was perfect when I
got to college I wanted to think I was
always able to shoot one of the things
coach Townsend made me do was
I'm with your son you're gonna work from
the inside out you're gonna make sure
that you have a be able to post up
because that's what big man does you
know that's what big men do and then
take it out he didn't let me shoot very
much jump shots in college and so when I
got to the pros everybody like oh my god
you can so maybe you know maybe if I was
playing in this era I probably would try
but I don't think I would have been a
great three-point threat you know my
game was you know getting in the block
shooting from about 16 17 feet out then
the further out you go you know he go I
mean we had other guys who can who could
shoot that better than me so I just did
my thing on the inside
he's Patrick Ewing official title is the
associate head coach of the Charlotte
Hornets hypothetically if your alma
mater calls if the job is open what do
you do well you know I just want to say
you know I'm roomful coats for JT 3 I
think he's done an outstanding job
therefore he's been there about 13 years
he's going through a tough time right
now you know I'm hoping that they can
turn it around my son is on that staff
but you know if they call it on foot if
that if that if something happens and
they call I would listen but you know my
goal is to be a head coach in the NBA
but I was definitely listen to what they
have to say but yeah for them yeah I'm
wondering what's what's going on there I
don't know how this plays out but might
not be good for JT 3 you know you're
gonna have ups and downs you know right
now it's what they had a two-year down
period you know I don't think that's
enough of a down period to let him go
especially all the rich history and
things that come with a university so
you know I'm hoping that they'll give
him you know another shot and he can
turn it around you watching any of the
tournament I haven't been watching any
of it yet I think it just started ya
know we're so busy trying to try to make
a run and get these guys focused on
trying to make a run to try to get into
the playoffs
I haven't had time to watch it then we
got asked out all these game I'm right
now the TV's on ESPN right now I'm just
watching the highlights who were you
scouting so you are you going out to
scout and then no no no we watch them
you watch it on tape I'm saying we have
we have we have someone that goes
without one scout then they they they do
a report and we watched film on the on
the team that we're scouting and then we
you know look at what he wrote and then
what we've seen we write up a report and
you had to turn it into the head coach
your MVP this year's who you know what
I'm not sure you know I haven't watched
enough enough college basketball no no I
mean I'm making the pros Oh in the
league League Westbrook Westbrook oh
that was good
he's averaging a triple-double
I mean I you know people talk about you
know Oscar when he did it I I mean I
know I was alive but I was I think I was
probably living in Jamaica when he was
doing it but um you know Westbrook is
doing a fantastic job
even though harden harden you know he's
he's doing a great job as well but I
think Westbrook by far is the MVP could
LeBron ever get to a level where you
consider him better than Michael Jordan
no my you know Michael is the greatest
player in my era in my era LeBron LeBron
LeBron is great
that's Jordans wall on you right now on
your phone I think LeBron is great you
know you have to take your hats off to
him he's had a remarkable career but
Michael is the best player in my in my
era I mean you know the things that he's
done and was able to do and and they're
two different type players LeBron is a
facilitator and Michael was a killer
he's an assassin
you know you get him the ball and he's
looking to score you pass when needed
well most of the time he's gonna he's
looking to score could you deal with
Alonzo balls Dan if you know as
well you know you'd have to keep him out
of the locker room keeping modernity
they can stay in the family areas but
keep him locked up the court out of the
lap room and away from the team do you
think that Lavar ball could beat Michael
Jordan one on one back in the day as
Michael brought that up at all no I know
he has been around a little bit but no
yeah yeah I mean it's not even worth why
solver Barkley said he'd like to play
him now well I would like I'll let you
get back to work so you don't get yelled
at and good luck always great to hear
from you Patrick oh it's always good to
come on thank you I'm still waiting for
my invite to come up to you by the way
can you bring I want you in the man cave
but I also I would like for you to bring
one of your old Georgetown t-shirts you
know under your jersey and we didn't we
could frame it here in the man cave oh
do you have you have any of those
jerseys or t-shirts left no that's what
about 40 years ago yeah yeah they might
be dry rotted by now we want you in the
man cave I'll shoot hoops with you in
the man cave okay all right good luck
the rest of the season thank you that's
a Patrick Patrick Ewing every time every
time he comes on the reactions the same
I didn't know he had that kind of
personality he didn't share it because
he didn't trust people but you know the
New York media and not winning a
championship how he was viewed at
Georgetown but I didn't realize he had
that kind of personality until I went to
dinner with him in San Antonio years ago
during the NBA Finals and I was only
because I was with mark Jax and his good
friend yeah Paulie
I don't know if younger people can
realize what a big deal he was in
college from age 18
everyone I knew bought a Georgetown hat
or jacket when he got to join us a bad
dude man John Thompson and Michael
Graham and all those guys Georgetown was
cool way before Allen Iverson got there
bad
dude bad dude the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience